my dad's a police officer in Miami hey
did you uh have you been seeing the
alien stuff did you see that in
bide
why defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins silit packed
with immune boosting properties CIT has
been scientifically proven to promote
respiratory health feing in oxygen
absorption while also making the body
infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the new
outbreak this winter don't forget to use
my discount code Ali dawa for 15% off
enjoy brothers and sisters and dear
friends what's going on in Miami and
Florida for those who are living there
there's a couple of videos we're going
to see in and react to there have been
claims and I eyewitnesses who have seen
some kind of creatures that look like
Shadows who are like solid you know it
looks like a shadow but it's like a
solid being or whatever is for that
matter who have been seen by multiple
people tall what Earth is this and what
does Islam have to say about this here
are some eyewitness testimonies who were
on the ground and hundreds of police
officers were sent there apparently
saying there was some kind of a a a
fight between that but I don't know how
that correlates with people saying that
they saw these objects what are they are
they Gins let's see for ourselves
hundreds of police officers helicopters
and more showed up where a call that
allegedly was teenagers fighting with
sticks that's what they are telling us
happen but have you ever seen a a police
response like this for a fight what if
the truth is so Sinister that once it
gets out there Pandora's Box will
forever be open it's said that 7 to 10t
tall creatures cloaked like something
from a predator movie and appearing as
Shadows was in that mall people inside
were firing gunshots at these creatures
and everyone was so scared that nobody
could even pull out a phone to record
they was in fight ORF flight mode and
they was fighing but this man later
recorded the truth watch this a few
Shadows but they were solid at the same
time and it's it almost look like they
was coming our Direction like they was
chasing us but they was disappearing and
reappearing closer so I'm like yo what
so we start really moving next thing you
know we start hearing more gunshots like
these dudes start F so guys you saw that
for yourself Subhan Allah in Islam we
have explanation to a lot of this stuff
uh why because we believe in Islam that
gin kind ex exist they exist they are
supernatural beings um that we cannot
see with a naked eye they come in the
form of uh snakes sometimes dogs
sometimes they are like the prophet P
him said they can fly around like the
wind Etc they can go from place to place
easily because we know that in the Quran
when if I'm not mistaken was one of the
jins who worked Witham and he went and
got to the throne in an instant he said
before you get up on your seat I will
have it here so some of them have these
abilities so we are told that Subhan
Allah that they exist they have live in
a different realm Allah Allah tells us
in the Quran that he created Mankind and
gin for no other reason except to
worship Him the purpose is to worship
God Almighty they live like us they they
have like opinions like us they have
decisions making factors like us um they
can chose they are disbeliever ones and
Believers ones are those who believe and
the prophet P him said from abdah M or
abdah abas if if I'm not mistaken that
every human being is appointed a gin
which calls you to certain desires or
whatever it may be the prophet P was
asked even you he said even mine but
mine has been made to submit by Allah
and some of the MU say that this means
that he uh the Jin that is appointed to
him became a Muslim or submitted for
that matter so we believe in these
things and they are a reality if you
look at how the pyramids were made and
all this kind of stuff these things
cannot be explained naturally so you can
see clearly brother and sisters that it
can be that for some odd reason whatever
it may be that they show theirself it
can be cannot be we don't know but we
believe in the Supernatural we believe
these phenomena we believe in these
things alhamdulillah Islam has a
solution even to the Unseen and
explanations and how to deal with it we
have our prayers that protects us uh we
have our that we do our morning and
evening supplication that we have to do
that protects Us from Evil ey black
magic physical harm unless Allah subh wi
it so we don't know what's exactly going
in Miami Florida but from what we know
people have witnessed this so much so
that people did not even record it
because they were so petrified of what
they saw that's the claims I don't know
it's all started according to police
with some sort of fight between juvenile
groups that were armed with sticks my
dad's a police officer in Miami and I
mean like he's even running for Sheriff
and I I just talked him he didn't say
anything about
that
hey hey did you uh have you've been
seeing the alien stuff did you see that
in a bide oh I'm to about it what are
you
serious you're you're joking you're
joking did they tell you not to talk
about it how many times you want me to
slice the pie I'm not allowed to about I
I do know what you're talking about but
I'm not allowed to talk about what can
you can you at least say like whatever
so okay so they're saying it's like a um
like a fight broke out why did they send
so many police
cars are you serious you can't say you
can't say any no
no help damn bro if you are into this
kind of stuff and you believe or you
witnessed it Islam has a direct answer
to these things alhamdulillah and you
can look into it Gins we believe in Gins
in Islam they are created of smokeless
fire uh and the angels are created of
light and the mankind is created of clay
or Earth should we say uh for that
matter and that's what I want to say I
don't know what the hell's going on
seems a bit Booky but yes has Gins taken
over Miami or Florida I don't know you
guys tell me who lives there is this a
fake story what is it but people have
seen it but may Allah subh protect us
and you have things to do to protect us
that is mentioned by Allah because Allah
is the one who's created that realm and
our realm and he has given us protocols
to protect ourselves to an next time
brother and
sisters